the evil Lord for tech is planning to  take over all the lego dimensions  to defeat him you'll need might I'm  Batman  extra might okay I'm here you'll need  gigawatts magic time trouble I talk you  eyes you'll need teams new teams awesome  cars rebuild source of cars but we've  rebuilt awesome cars good cops bad rats  wall Spinjitzu  unikitty battle rights excavators Scooby  Snax troops attitude proton packs  muscles and the greatest weapon of all  imagination you can use any vehicle  build any hero  in any world  let go dimension you're gonna need a  bigger imagination starter that includes  three characters in one vehicle some  toys and consoles sold separately rated  everyone 10 and up